on veut savoir tuer personne te connais
la seule chose que je sais c'est que tu
t'appelles lucas des videurs et a
fracassé un mec que tu as lycée pour moi
je voulais ce que je veux c'est que tu
bosses pour moi c'est simple le dernier
debout hilal poste
[Musique]
tu commence vendredi tu fais tout ce que
je te dise et leur petit chien est
affilié tout le reste tout seul quand tu
vas bosser
c'est tout à fait ça un gros travail
[Musique]
la première fois que je t'ai vu c'est ce
que je me suis dit ce gars là ce soit un
fêlé complet soit [ __ ] de survivants
moment de craquer a besoin de toi et ta
fille aussi
[Musique]
s'il arrive quoi que ce soit ma fille
foutu
[Musique]